i'm gonna do that again because that was
terrible wait what's my line again the
stars of your favorite marvel
blockbusters already face quite a bit of
pressure on set so it's common for them
to forget their lines from time to time
even some of the biggest names to take
on these marvelous roles will
occasionally flub up their dialogue
while on set these are the marvel stars
who forgot their lines and action rachel
weiss may have been the only actor in
the black widow cast to have won an
oscar but according to her castmates she
was the one who forgot her lines the
most on set
electromagnetic fox fields
in fact it was pew who had to remind
weiss as well as her other co-stars what
exactly her lines were despite david
harbour saying the opposite who's most
likely to forget their lines
rachel oh rachel yeah yeah rachel why
are you saying me dude for as long as
scarlett johansson has been playing
black widow even she has a few slip ups
johansson felt that at times the lengthy
shoot would make her scatterbrained to
the point where she would annoy florence
pugh with any of her slip ups tell me
exactly
we bring to mind at least scarjo seems
to be a good sport about it all if
you're so sure then tell me what
happened tell me exactly
jake gyllenhaal has starred in plenty of
iconic roles but even he struggles with
his lines from time to time gyllenhaal
revealed in an interview that he
struggled with mysterio's techno babble
especially in the scene where mysterio
first meets peter parker which was the
very first scene he shot on set actors
are not the sharpest tools in [ __ ]
regardless of whether or not that may be
true gyllenhaal has still provided
audiences with a fascinating villain in
mysterio
benedict cumberbatch may have a knack
for playing such serious characters in
movies and shows like sherlock and the
imitation game but he certainly loves to
play the class clown on set even when in
costume as the sorcerer's supreme or in
an emotional scene cumberbatch sometimes
gets so caught up in his shenanigans
that it will lead him to forget his
lines you've
figured out a way for
to
so wait see even doctor strange can have
some fun on set you've figured out a way
to regenerate no
tom holland's portrayal of spider-man is
beloved by fans all over the world but
not even his popularity prevents him
from messing up his lines on occasion
even something as seemingly simple as
shaking hands with jake gyllenhaal's
mysterio can cause holland to forget
what he was supposed to say next
honestly though who can blame him i mean
who wouldn't be starstruck shaking hands
with the one and only jake gyllenhaal
robert downey jr will admit that he's
not the best when it comes to keeping
his lines memorized in fact it is widely
known that downey will never say the
same line twice while filming so in
order to fix this problem downey would
often have an assistant feed him his
lines through an earpiece while he's
filming fine suits me fly safe
the more we learn about downey the more
we see that he may very well be the
real-life tony stark you're gonna have a
gag reel on this like smoking a bandit
jeremy renner has been making waves as
hawkeye since his cameo in the first
thaw film but even he still struggles to
remember his lines while filming his
tense fight scene against scarlett
johansson's black widow renner got a bit
too into the scene that he forgot what
he was supposed to say what the [ __ ] is
the line i forgot that must have been
quite awkward paul bettany is already
uncomfortable in all of his vision
prosthetics and makeup but even he
sometimes wrestles with delivering his
lines smoothly and efficiently during
the civil war scene where vision defends
wanda to general ross he started to
stumble over his own words it's maximum
that have some
[ __ ]
just imagining all of the outtakes with
betany in his vision getup makes us
laugh
ms maximoff manipulates molecular pillar
to grow for
ryan reynolds has always shown just how
committed he is to playing the merc with
a mouth and his love for improv but when
it comes to non-improv scenes even
somebody with the confidence of reynolds
can mess up every so often russell's not
going to kill anyone because regardless
of the gaff reynolds still very much
seems to be in character even when
forgetting what his next line was
because
of you
jennifer lawrence has always stood out
in the hollywood crowd for her more down
to earth demeanor so even when she
messes up every now and then lawrence is
still perfectly able to carry it on with
humor i'm caught
this is uh
even if she's having trouble pronouncing
a simple name
wagner
chris hemsworth was able to drop the
constant stoic nature of thor for the
taika waititi directed ragnarok which
allowed him to let loose a little bit
more than usual but even the god of
thunder messes up his lines on several
occasions the wise king never seeks out
honestly chris hemsworth still looks
cool even when he's forgetting his lines
it's one step every time it gets me
chris evans had a lot of weight put onto
his shoulders portraying the iconic role
of captain america but he's human just
like the rest of us it even got to
points where it would require multiple
takes until evans could get the line
right
find out what the ghost wants
let's get this ghost we still love you
cap
before taking on the iconic role of loki
hiddleston was already an acclaimed
thespian in british theater hiddleston
had that kind of charisma and charm that
even his slip-ups felt natural
the avengers
mascot
this still feels like a classic loki
moment even if it was just hiddleston
fumbling on his lines
mark ruffalo had already built quite the
resume before joining the mcu as bruce
banner aka the incredible hulk when he's
not wearing his mocap suit on set as the
raging green hero ruffalo has to get
quite wordy as the brainy banner in fact
the scientific banter can get too much
for ruffalo that at times he'll
completely blank on his lines
chloropotent cells inside a xylo
in all honesty ruffalo is doing a much
better job speaking in scientific lingo
than most people could it's part of the
challenge of playing bruce banner
polysaccharide
tilda swinton is an academy
award-winning actress with a huge
pedigree but if there's one thing we've
learned it's that your reputation and
experience doesn't seem to matter as
much when it comes to getting your lines
right but every miracle
every medical miracle
at this point it is unavoidable even
when starring as dr strange's
all-knowing mentor the ancient one
perpetuated the illusion the delusion
that you can
what do i say
there's hundreds of mutant characters
that exist in the x-men universe so it
would be impressive for anybody to know
them all so it is only human that
michael fassbender forgot a few while
filming the tension-filled airplane
argument in x-men days of future past
all dead
countless others
can't remember their names for the life
of me there was a lot of them
part of michael rooker's appeal is just
how well he balances his gruff
personality while simultaneously feeling
appealing to the audience rooker
sometimes became so in tune with his
character of yondu that he got carried
away and completely spaced on what he
was supposed to say next quadrant
[Music]
kurt russell was perfectly cast as the
star-lord's megalomaniacal father ego in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. but do
not expect an mcu newcomer to always get
their disney franchises right which is
what happened in this incident now past
the edge of what's known we've heard
tell about the man they call star wars
wrong movie kurt
before her character was unveiled as the
evil mastermind known as the power
broker in the falcon and the winter
soldier emily van camp felt like she
botched the first scene she shot for
captain america the winter soldier all
due respect if shield is
i knew
thankfully van camp was able to get more
time to shine in subsequent marvel films
and shows gwyneth paltrow has always
shined as tony stark's loyal and loving
wife pepper potts and she has proved to
have quite the career outside of the mcu
as well though even paltrow messes up
from time to time and this scene in iron
man 3 in particular took more than a few
takes
what challenging the world's biggest
term let's try that again what is not
normal is you challenging them
nobody is perfect even the stars behind
some of the biggest movies in the world
mess up from time to time whether it be
stumbling on science and tech talk
explaining the history of marvel or even
a simple line it's understandable that
these actors and actresses have their
moments when they mess up do you have a
favorite slip up from a marvel star